bang-bang I am here with a keen Sawyer
we'll get into the name in a second
super excited to have you so thanks so
much for for coming to do this yeah
thanks for having me
all right we're gonna start off real hot
we got to talk about your name a keen
Sawyer we're just talking about it you
gave give a good laugh
Sawyer spell with two R's yep right so s
aww ye or R that's correct
tell us a story yeah I mean so the basic
story is I have I think my great-great
grandfather decided to sort of branch
off from the main family line inside add
an extra hour just to be different and
so now we've you know we have this curse
of my name always being corrected I have
I have official documents with a single
arrow over it and it's just not worth
changing anymore so I have like Bank
cars that haven't misspelled and it's
like whatever yeah long as you have my
social security number like it should be
fine
and so Sawyer is a common last name in
West Africa oh yeah so I think so I
think it comes from like busy from safe
slave trade I think there was probably
like a group of Sawyer's that came back
till I bury it to Freetown okay but a
number of them decided to sort of
basically trace their roots back to
where they thought they were from so you
have Sawyer's all through West Africa
from Liberia to Ghana to Nigeria where I
grew up so but it's it's one I think
generally it's one big family that has
links yeah linkages and so and one dude
was just like hey mate we're putting the
Double R on and roll yeah and so I have
that which is unique but it's more it's
more trouble than it's worth to be
honest with you yeah III guess if
there's a single or then people actually
think that's how it's spelled right
where is the double or that's the one
that they think they should be correct
yeah at the very least two if it's a
double are that you know it's like an
African Sawyer as opposed to like a
Sawyer from somewhere else maybe maybe
that's maybe that's worth it I love it
alright so let's go back to you grew up
in Nigeria yes I did so I was born in
Massachusetts actually okay but a few
months after I was born my parents moved
back
to Nigeria my parents were here for
college and grad school and decided to
move back afterwards and we're in
Nigeria gee grow up so I grew up in
Lagos my guess is the it's probably the
largest city in Africa now population
wise yeah but it used to be the
political capital as well of Nigeria but
that was moved I think about 25 years
ago was it was moved to a brand new city
that was built from the ground up but
Lagos is still the commercial capital of
Nigeria so I wanted to do this interview
and not tell you what I'm about to tell
you until you got here I went two years
ago or three years ago to Lagos okay and
you know all the Westerners although
other white people they stay on Victoria
Island they hang out at the hotels and
all the stuff but the the friend that I
went with he basically had a buddy that
lived in in Lagos in your computer
village okay yeah so we stayed in a
hotel and we pulled up they had the
guards outside with the aks
and the first night I was like hey man
why are there cars outside and it was
when you were looking at me like yeah I
get that they got eight caves but if
someone starts shooting all those guys
are gonna stick around and it was a
really cool experience though because we
would walk to computer village and for
those that don't know computer villages
basically I don't we'd say six block by
like ten block area that's just packed
with electronics and computer there's
massive yeah and you get anything fixed
there you can buy anything there it's an
interesting phenomenon it's a huge
market yeah and so when I came back from
that trip I actually wrote some that
published publicly just said look I saw
the future of technology it was that
entire area was taking people who
previously didn't have access to
internet computing electronics etc and
over you know that been 10 years or so
before I'd went and visited they had
gone from very little access to now it
was highly connected there was great
interest ruk sure they had all the same
devices right they had all those
smartphones all this kind of stuff and
there's a lot of people and it's growing
incredibly fast and I don't think that a
lot of people here in North America
understand kind of the the demographic
dynamics that are at play especially in
Nigeria but but
other African countries as well yeah
yeah I mean I mean I think the African
continent is part of the youngest
continent in the world right and so if
you talk about demographics every just
about everywhere in the West you know
birth rates are dropping I think it's
it's acute in Japan where you know there
have empty houses because there are
enough people right to play to replace
the old population
I think demographically Africa is
extremely young lots of young people
lots of labor and it's a massively
untapped resource when you think about
it relative to the rest of the world and
I think investors are beginning to
understand that you know the Africa is
the next frontier it's the next big
market and you're seeing people
beginning to vote with their money all
right with investments continue to
increase but to go back you know to
FinTech and the startup ecosystems
across Africa are growing and you have
more and more sources of funding just
coming in yeah so give us you've got a
big focus on African countries and so
maybe give us kind of like a Leyland
Africa is not one country or it's a
continent that's made up of a bunch of
different countries and obviously when
you have those different countries
there's different parts of the continent
like how do you view the connectivity
kind of the tech ecosystems etc across
Africa is there generalizations in terms
of the West versus the East or the north
for south or is it really country by
country specific yeah so it's it's kinda
like ecosystems right okay so I think
Nigeria is large enough that it's an
entity unto itself
you know there's a lot of tech
innovation around just payments and
financial services out of Kenya because
m-pesa was basically it's probably the
most successful mobile payments
deployment arguably anywhere in the
world in terms of just adoption within
the country and so you know Kenya's
large as well but East Africa is almost
like a block okay I think some of it is
because of just how close those
countries are in terms of you know the
Union they have and with and so in many
ways it's like there's a large ecosystem
going out of like you know East Africa
with Kenya
Kampala Rwanda now kind of coming up
Nigeria is 200 million people so it's an
antenna of itself we have pockets of
development in Ghana and in South Africa
right so the Africa is a large country
um probably the most developed right so
it kind of sits on its own and two
logics then North Africa is sort of
separate like I think oftentimes people
think about sub-saharan Africa and the
northern Africans have sort of more of
allegiance with the Middle East and and
certain parts of Europe but I think you
know I kind of see it as three or four
core ecosystems with like anchor cities
that sort of then bring you know lots of
the region together for sure and help me
understand like where's the education
coming from right so when I was there
what it felt like to me was there was a
lot of now that there's connectivity hey
the Internet is this portal to
information and to education and access
to other people and things like that or
is that true outside of Lagos Rick is it
to me kind of way you're saying like
Lagos is almost feels like a little bit
different than some of the other cities
or is that one thread that's throughout
all of these different ecosystems so it
varies right so I mean so Nigeria in
particularly you have Lagos which is a
huge city which takes a lion's share of
all the tech investments right the tech
ecosystem there is pretty dynamic lots
of investors come in alright so Legos
kind of is the center of tech in Nigeria
but then you have you know pockets in
the east southeast of Nigeria like yo
port on our court which is basically an
oil city but has now sort of begun to
evolve into a knowledge city right and
you know thing about tech that's
interesting and particularly like you
know coding on software development is
you have a lot of people who are just
smart who never really had access to
higher education who are self-taught
right like you said with connectivity
it's sort of like an apprenticeship
system where you have a really good
developer and he just brings up the next
generation right so there's a lot of
kind of like an apprenticeship type
approach where as the ecosystem grows
it's trying to kind of replicate itself
right and there are people who don't
have frankly other options right because
it's either that university admission is
very limited and even if you do gain
admission to universities the quality is
just terrible
right so for young people who are coming
out of high school
the smart thing to do is figure out how
to learn to code and as much as possible
kind of hack your way through the system
right so you talk about computer village
but your computer is full of hackers who
are basically self-taught technologists
right they took apart computers they
figured out how to work they forgot to
put it back together all right so
there's this culture of just trying to
figure things out on your own and just a
very strong culture of entrepreneurship
and I think you find that in Nigeria in
particular you know but it shows up
differently in other countries you know
some other countries have just better
education so you'd go to Ghana in my
view and you'd have a lot more
University taught developers right
because the university system there is
frankly better and just about other
parts just about almost any other
country in Africa I think you have a
slightly better higher education system
night Nigeria as a whole so it looks
different depending on the country but
all know you know I think the narrative
is lots of young people who are hungry
who are looking for you know who see a
future and tech and see a way to kind of
to get there yeah and you mentioned the
kind of like the spirit of
entrepreneurship the the most
fascinating part of the entire trip to
me was we went and watched a couple of
in the US what we call soccer but but
obviously football games there and
literally how we would watch them is we
would basically walk up to what kind of
looks like you're walking to somebody's
like backyard yeah and you pay them a
little bit of money you know it
basically like a dollar equivalent here
in the US and you literally walk and
they've set up benches in front of TVs
there's exposed wires running to know
what's of these TVs and it's not like
two people are watching I mean these
things are packed with you know 40 50
people all sitting there watching these
games together and and what essentially
has happened is these young
entrepreneurs I figured out hey if I can
figure out how to get a TV get cable to
that TV get the soccer games on and then
charge people to come in just like a bar
would or anything exactly it's pretty
incredible to see that entrepreneurial
type you know spirit at work even the
things that aren't tech related right I
mean that's just hey people want to
watch this game and I've got the ability
to give it to them
think that spirit spills over and a lot
of tech things you're talking about as
well yeah you're right and I think a lot
of is out of necessity right it's like
look I need to make a living one way or
the other and people look for a way to
provide a service in any way they can
right so you're right you have all these
pop-up bars that you know show up doing
your Premier League soccer games on a
Saturday or a Sunday and literally
someone's like business where they have
one cable they have a good TV and you
know they charge people to come and
watch the games and sell them alcohol
and food right so you'll see that across
you know many African countries where
you have just just this issue of so this
comes a call like non-consumption
okay where for the vast majority of
Africans like at the bottom of the
pyramid they can't afford cable they
can't afford to have their own setup and
so what you end up having is Sonia has
figured out a way to take some commodity
right and make it cost-effective for
everyone so now that TV and that cable
box is a shared resource for the street
or the neighborhood and it now makes it
accessible right and so I think it's the
same way even with you know I guess
we're going to get into crypto but even
the way crypto is prolific across Africa
a lot of it is actually intermediated
out of necessity right you have people
that are tech savvy they have figured
out ways to buy and acquire Bitcoin you
know that Bitcoin can be used to settle
global transactions and they essentially
become intermediaries for businesses who
say look I need to import you know
mobile phones for example I need a
market I can access US Dollars and some
guy says look I can get you those phones
I can sell that transaction with Bitcoin
like you don't know how to you don't
need to know how to use Bitcoin and you
just need to know a guy right and and so
a lot of the industry is actually
proliferating that way where the some
guy who's figured this thing out
he's charging me a fee after a while I
figure out what he's doing and then I
cut him out because well I could figure
it out myself
right and so that's I think how a lot of
things proliferate across Africa and
with crypto it's not different yeah and
I think part of what's fascinating to me
about some of these markets so the
African countries for sure India I've
heard some similar stories where people
also aren't going on to like traditional
exchanges to buy
coin they'll literally walk over to a
computer village or you have some other
area and they'll hand somebody physical
cash and basically get Bitcoin in what's
kind of like a black market type trade
yeah and I remember when I was there in
Lagos that's actually how we switched
u.s. dollars into the local currency was
not at the airport where they're gonna
take you know 20% and quote you some
ridiculous exchange rate it was a guy in
a village basically and so it's pretty
interesting to see how like those
systems already exist without crypto and
now crypto is just being fit into how
they're culturally the people of a
certain country operate yeah so I mean
so you said that that there's these
well-worn distribution channels that
exist and you know 80% of Africa is
unbanked or underbanked seem crazy right
similarly for the economies their
majority and formal so whenever you see
a country that has like a banking sector
like it's oftentimes a lot smaller than
it should be right you know banks in
Nigeria primarily serve the government
by buying government debt they might
serve some large conglomerates that are
chummy with the government but that's
really it there's no like active lending
market on a retail time from a retail
perspective but in that same country in
Nigeria we have what we call like
savings groups
Susu groups where literally there are
networks of people that lend and borrow
to each other right these affinity
groups and some of them run into the
hundreds of thousands right of people of
members what right and and the funny
thing is most of these systems
particularly Nigeria still they're still
run by like paper and pen right physical
Ledger's physical relationships your
credit score is based on oh yeah I know
your uncle and I knew your brother and
they were good for the money so you're
gonna be good for it right because I
mean the one thing that a lot of African
cultures have is like the family name is
very important right and so oftentimes
credit is determined by what family
you're from because they know for
example well if I lend you money and you
sort of get in trouble your family will
bill you out to preserve the family name
right and so there are all these kind of
social ways in which credit and the
sophisticated and we how credit is
determined but they're all off the books
they're all non digitized and I think
the huge opportunity is now taking some
of these cultural norms and figuring out
ways to kind of digitize them such that
you can still capture the you know those
you know those systems for our credit
risk is determined but now you have a
digital platform as interoperable that
gets into the world right you can start
harvesting this data and actually now
pumping a lot more capital into these
into these countries tell me more about
the savings groups ahead of those work
so savings groups arm they're all over
Africa and have different names I can so
in in Kenya that called Sacco's
right now Kenya and can in the East
Africans they're they're a lot more
regulated in that you can get a license
to be a Saco in Kenya and so you're
effectively like a bank right or Credit
Union is probably the best corollary and
and basically it's the typically rolls
out of these affinity groups where for
example it could be a group of cattle
you know cattle farmers and it's in our
best interest to basically pull money
together such that we can expand our
assets right so you have ten Californa
man afford to buy a new cow and expand
its flock but if you all contribute
money to a fund and we will rotate you
know taking out that fund every month so
and buys a new cow right and it's funded
by the group right and so savings groups
typically rose out of affinity groups
like farmers or market women who for
example you know you might have Marco
women like a dozen of them all sell
oranges and they say look let's get
together form a savings group and we
also can extract pricing power from our
wholesalers right because you can now
buy in bulk so all these systems are
developed through you know particular
groups of people that are in the same
industry
they're basically pooling capital to
grow their businesses but also like
sharing knowledge because the after
effect of that is look if we're all cow
errors right and we're all invested in
each other if one of us figures out a
better way to get you know an increase
yield of milk well I want to tell
everyone because all invested in each
other right so it's it's in my best
interest to share information to share
now
such that because I mean the better you
are deploying my capital the more likely
it is I'm gonna get a return all right
so that's how I think a lot of these
savings group typically grew in parts of
East Africa they're more formalized in
certain ways with rules and you know
actual regulations around them in places
like Nigeria they're kind of pretty much
off the books and for a lot of people
that is the financial services they
access right that's how some people know
borrow money to send their kids to
university abroad that's how people
borrow money to buy a car so I could be
an uber driver for example and all those
things are informal and the real
opportunity is how do you now take those
informal things and systems and digitize
them it's fascinating
one of the frameworks that has really
caught my attention I think I've started
to pay more attention to over time is
this idea that you know that 80%
unbanked or underbanked most people I
think would look and say you know
African countries were very far behind
the West well over the last 5-10 years
there's been kind of this leapfrog
effect when it comes to at least mobile
banking right right so things like and
pace obviously helped usher that in but
there's others as well talk a little bit
about how you know is there an advantage
for technologists who are building
without the legacy systems in place dude
are they able to kind of accelerate the
adoption and development or is that
maybe just there's some edge cases where
people point to and say yeah that
happened but that might not be the norm
so I'd say yes or no depends on the
context right or the country I think
there are scenarios where so so I'll
kind of paint two stories right in Kenya
with m-pesa you had sort of like certain
things that aligned themselves you had a
governor who backed it you had a telco
that had I think about 80% market share
right Safaricom and you had an incentive
system that allowed agents agent
networks to be built out right so the
commission based system and what was
happening in the earlier when peso was
that I could be middle class person with
a great job and I actually fund like
five payout points right literally go to
those stores pay for
them to get the infrastructure pay for
them to stand it up and then it's a
business I'm funding I get the return as
the investor right and so that ensured
that passive proliferated because you
had all these points where you could
spend and use it so the distribution
channel was incentivized to grow you had
massive company I had singular market
share just about everyone had a
Safaricom phone so many things oh and
then the government really backed it
right it's a number of things aligned
and all of a sudden now you have this
core infrastructure which is mobile
money that you know became basically
larger than cash now once you have that
ecosystem where there was orders of
magnitude of GDP flowing through and
Pesa people started iterating on that by
doing lending with MSHA Jiri and all
these innovations on top of because you
had a core payment platform in place now
in Nigeria it kind of evolved a little
bit differently because in Nigeria you
had very powerful incumbent banks and
you had telcos and there was sort of
like you know a lot of telcos were more
diverse in terms of the makeup of
capital right MTN is the largest at
South African you had Airtel that had
some Arab money invested but for the
form for most cases Nigerian banks are
primarily wholly owned by Nigerians so
politically the banks had more power and
the banks wanted to ensure that no one
encroached on the power they had in the
financial system so the way more money
has not evolved as well in Nigeria is
because regulation and banking power has
stifled things and up until I think this
year telcos were not allowed to get into
mobile money
I think MTN just got the first license
as part of this why did that change um I
think it changed because for a couple of
reasons I think one because it was clear
that the Nigerian model for mobile
morning was failing it was clear that
even if I look at the most of FinTech
lots of funding has gone in the FinTech
it's still catering to the banked right
so it's an improvement on the user
experience for folks who are already
banked right so I have a bank account
but now I have an app that we make ussd
payments
sale but it still attached to my bank
account right the guy that it doesn't
have a bank account it's not going to
use that product so if you think of
what's been happening in Niger in
particular is a lot of induration has
been basically just cannibalizing the
same group of customers right within the
same PI it's not really growing the pie
and I think I think the central bank in
Nigeria is realizing one way or the
other that that model is not getting the
results that it should be and other
countries are moving ahead so it's
either that you change course and say
look the telcos are frankly naturally
the best place for mobile money to
operate out of right because they own
the core infrastructure people are
effectively in even in Nigeria
effectively finding hacks around mobile
money like in Nigeria day what people
were doing was you know most cell phone
services across Africa and in Nigeria
has prepaid so you buy a scratch card
you scratch off a code and you load up
money onto your phone now while pool
we're doing was you know you could
actually buy a scratch card right get on
the phone and I owe someone money across
the country so Ravin like send him 50
bucks which I can't really get to him
I'll just buy a scratch card in Lagos
right and give him the code over the
phone or text it to him and that
basically is money right because he can
take that code and either and load up
his phone or he can resell it at a
discount right so he could say look
someone said my food our crash cart
actually need the cash you need to buy
credit
I'll sell to you for 48 bucks right so
I'll give you an incentive to basically
get a discount so people were already
using these mobile services actually
same on platforms so it tells you that
there is a market that says look I want
to use this utility in this phone as a
way to transact and so I think the niger
models being a shift I think MTN has
gotten a license and other tell girls
will follow I think we should get you
know a better outcome a better result I
think I think it's literally just look
the current policy isn't working and
there's a lot of frustration in the
system as to why we're not getting the
results in terms of financial inclusion
that that the government is targeting
yeah in speaking of government what is
the general
of like the trust in the government
right so some countries around the world
there's fairly democratic processes
people yeah they know bad stuff happens
but for the most part they trust their
governments or at least don't think
their governments are actively working
against them in other parts it's clear
as day hey my country government is
corrupt and you know nobody here trusts
them where do some of these African
countries actually fall in that spectrum
I'm so probably the lower end of the
scale okay um in terms of they they
don't have high degrees yeah so a lack
of trust in the system right and it's it
varies right some countries are
improving and getting better and are
better governed and now in a more
positive trajectory but I'd say like the
bulk of African countries at the very
least the citizens look at the
government very high suspicion because I
mean the right for corruption I think my
joy is the model for that rifle
corruption weak infrastructure people
are not seeing like physical investments
they're not seeing their lives improve
right and you're also in a system where
most things are informal right I'll say
now earlier today in another
conversation that you know part of
problem in Nigeria as a nation is you
know the majority of government revenue
comes from oil sales I always bought by
foreign multinationals and foreign
entities right so the Nigerian
government frankly is getting no revenue
from the people and so even just that
tells you that they're more likely to do
the bidding of countries buying their
oil right and setting it up such that
that revenue continues than serving the
populace and their and their people
their catering to their customer exactly
and the customer is not a Nigerian
citizen all right Nigerian is just
someone you just have to make sure you
know things don't tip over to revolution
right and so but what that is created to
your point is you know very very low
trust in government very low trust in
institutions very low trust in banks
anything that's formal typically comes
with some level of a sense that that
ends any genetic advantage of me as a
citizen and not give me like my do I
think that's created a system where it's
not only a little trust but people have
to fend for themselves right even just
like getting power reliable power as a
part
Nigeria right and so I think what that's
created is a properties that really says
look I'm in it for me I need to figure
out things for myself and I think
because of that in many ways I think you
have a you have a captive audience for
crypto the script is the ultimate like
individual sovereignty tool that look I
can kind of take things on my own I now
have a currency every transact and by
the way the government doesn't really
care about me anyway right and so when I
so it also goes back to when people talk
about regulation as an issue I think for
most African countries the regular
doesn't even have the wherewithal to
know what's even going on in those
countries let alone have any policy that
can stop crypto in any material away
yeah it's almost like the lack of
sophistication gives them less insight
right so everything's cash based if
everything's kind of gray or black
market type transactions you have these
informal economies these savings groups
etc that can't you know in the u.s. the
government knows what's happening cuz
they look at the data right they exactly
everything's kind of documented in some
way I ever seen interviewed congressman
Davidson from Ohio and he at one point
even said look we've essentially
empowered the banks to spy on their
customers for the government right right
well if the people don't trust banks in
Nigeria or some other you know African
country so they don't put their wealth
there well the government has no clue
what they're doing right and so it's
almost like that the regulations can't
affect them right the difference between
setting regulation and enforcing
regulations exactly if you have no way
to enforce it then you might as well not
even have the regulation to some degree
exactly and I think and I think that's
that's the nature of what's on the
ground in in the majority of countries
so that makes it very very interesting
and then you think about it to the fact
that there are many industries or many
sectors that are just green fields like
it's like there's no no one is servicing
those people right I think it creates a
massive opportunity because you don't
have a lot of incumbents to like work to
have to fight against right you know the
banking lobby United States is pretty
powerful right the understatement of the
entire class it's hard to see them be on
the losing side of some sort of grand
bargain right now in Africa
most people don't even have bad
so you're not even competing with those
entities you're now trying to you're
busy competing with creating a pathway
our product that people can afford to
consume but you're trying to solve the
problem inherently and if you can figure
out ways to sort of provide utility to
that marketplace figure out a good UI
and UX to serve them then as a massive
opportunity because I think inherently
the way I kind of see Africa evolving is
it's it's the ideal place for 10 power
like sovereign individuals
I said ideal Pitt way to say look you
can be your own bank you can be your own
financial service provider and moreover
you can be networked to this global
marketplace where you can acquire
products from anywhere right so I see a
future where Africans will source
mortgages source loans globally not from
their local banks it'll be from some you
know blockchain based protocol where
they can source you know capital from
cheap you know low or negative interest
environments figure out ways to program
you know to take out the risk in terms
of interest rate risk you just kind of
figure out ways to program it into it
and all of a sudden you have a product
that couldn't like sell like you know
you know hundreds of millions of people
that yeah I had access so before we get
to the crypto and blockchain stuff the
last question for you is are there
examples where the dish trust in the
institutions and the banks etc the banks
have like done bad stuff or is it more
of just hey I don't think you have my
best interest at heart because you know
your customers somebody else and it's
more kind of psychological or are there
examples where you know at the Cyprus
where they know they took 10% of our
money right and and they actually seized
assets or are there that type of
examples or is it more kind of
psychological there's there's some of
those but they they kind of it kind of
become things like so you think the
nature of banks particularly you know
lots of African banks Nigerian banks
they tend to see their customers as a
revenue source okay
right sorry large money in the bank and
all of a sudden I start seeing all these
weird fees I have this stamp duty this
fee
so there are all these costs but then
all these weird shenanigans are tend to
happen where you know I might have a
savings account and a checking account
and it might cost me a small fee to move
money between my accounts all of a
sudden you see that I made fifty
transactions between my two those two
accounts which I never initiated but
somehow someone in the bank maybe due to
weak controls or something there's some
nefarious activity where they're now
creating systems to basically tax pool
or charge me for things I didn't
authorize so it's works right like if
they just seize the money at least yeah
they took my money but this is like a
like a silent theft of the money and and
anything is anything that I think in
Boulder's institutions is the lack of
just strong civil organizations like
it's very little recourse right so I
have a couple of thousand bucks in the
bank like am I gonna sue the bank like I
don't even have the resources to hire
someone so the power dynamic is is so
skewed that powerful institutions can
get away with all sorts of all sorts of
you know illegal activity and get away
with it so I as the customer has very
little recourse and you know lots of
strong reasons to distrust these
institutions so what do people do with
their wealth like where do they store
their money pre crypto and knowing about
that and then what's the culture of
investing versus savings so a lot of
people a lot of people still store I
think the biggest store value out say
Nigeria is real estate okay right so I
think kinda like in the US as this
culture of oh I want to have a house
that I can live in I want to have a
house in my hometown I gets a source of
pride a source of oK you've made it
right so I moved to the city and I have
really made it till I build a house back
home right so there's just a general
culture of having property but I think
out of necessity it's the one store of
value that just about everyone I mean
practically makes sense to put money
into it because even in high
inflationary environments there will be
asset inflation - right so it's sort of
vibration drives the asset price right
right and so you sort of have this
inflation somewhat inflation-protected
asset it's easier to acquire land and
physical property you can see it
and then even for like nefarious and
illegal activity it's easy to hide money
money in a house right I can I can I can
hide it behind a corporate structure I
could have it as my cousin actually is a
beneficial owner when I am right so
typically like I think the primary store
value partially because you don't have a
lot of financial innovation in terms of
just other asset classes the stock
markets are relatively small as I said
most of the environment is informal so
people's wealth is typically starred in
landed property or maybe in a business
that they're running but even businesses
tend to be more cash flow entities right
people tend to take cash out of their
businesses and store it in housing as
opposed to grow necessarily grow the
business because there's a lot of risk
and tying up capital for lots of people
in their business all sorts of external
risks which disincentivize people from
wanting to kind of grow their businesses
it's more about cash flow what can I get
today how can I turn that over and how
can I store it God um let's talk about
Bitcoin then we'll do D credit no we do
kind of the broader ecosystem sure how
does Bitcoin fit into this and and how
do you think about awareness and
adoption of Bitcoin across the various
ecosystems in Africa so I mean I think
it's it's one of those things that if
you don't because our markets are
storing formal I think a lot of people
underestimate what's going on right I
think there lots of people who have been
historically cut off from global
financial services right literally your
ability to acquire things globally out
of a country like Nigeria if you're not
banked or fairly well connected is hard
you can't acquire for an exchange you
know a nigeria is a very very and a good
number of african countries are very
import dependent right so basically the
formula is you know foreign countries
like start extract raw materials they
create finished goods and they come back
and sell it to us right so everything
from cornflakes to rice like we import
everything right and because of that
lots of businesses are based out of
trade right sourcing goods putting a
margin on selling it off basic
necessities but you can imagine that
every time you have like an economic
like so the last recession Nigeria had
obviously of a sudden foreign exchange
got scarce because everyone wants
dollars either to store and how to hide
their value because the currency was
sure to depreciate or they needed
foreign exchange in increasing numbers
to keep buying their goods and running
their businesses but it was scarce right
and from that shock some people realized
oh there's this thing called Bitcoin I
can use to sell transactions right and I
don't need to kind of figure out to get
dollars on the street I don't go to
central bank and that out of necessity
got people into leverage in crypto and
so you had a handful of you know so like
Bitcoin based payment companies that
kind of came out of that you know some
of them got slapped on the wrist and got
into a little bit of trouble running
afoul of rules but basically that I
think was the first use case this idea
that I can settle global transactions
and acquire goods internationally to run
my business and I could use a Bitcoin
yeah it's fascinating to me that the
permissionless aspect of Bitcoin is
exactly like a product market fit for
those consumers right those people who
say it's not because I want to do
something that the authorities don't
want necessarily as much as it is I
don't have access right right and so the
permissionless nature of something like
Bitcoin is yes it can circumvent
Authority and kind of rules and
regulations at times but if you don't
have any access to begin with you aren't
worried about rules and regulations
because you don't have access right now
this says hey if you have an internet
connection you now get access yep it's
pretty is pretty special and then you
spend a bunch of time working on undie
cred so talk a little bit about what D
credit is kind of where your your
interest there is and then what what's
going on in Africa with D cred yeah so I
mean so a Saudi credit I mean at a high
level is iterating on Bitcoin right and
so is this idea that you can have a
solving store of value but we believe
that you know blockchain as a protocol
has and will have many many many many
more uses beyond just being a story
value medium of exchange right so I
think the either's Rd cred is this idea
that you can
you know a decentralized autonomous
organization right so a lot of what we
do adequate is effectively building all
the parts and features that would allow
us to evolve into this fully autonomous
entity right so things like governor's
become very very important because we
see ourselves more like almost like an
economy or a nation-state than just a
simple money protocol now you still have
to be a strong store of value you still
have to have all the security and I
think with our hybrid proof of war proof
of stake system you know you know for
you know where 20 percent 20 times more
secure than Bitcoin right but how does
that work so so so unlike Bitcoin your D
credit is a hybrid proof over proof of
stake protocol right
we still mine blocks similar to Bitcoin
we still gonna have a 21 million dollars
from 1 million supply but the difference
is every block as it's mined by miners
also has to be validated by proof of
stake holders so that's people who own
deck read you can buy what we call
tickets and this ticket basically gives
you a vote and what that vote
essentially does is every time a block
is mined there's a pool of this tickets
I think the optimal number is about
close to 41,000 of these tickets have
been purchased and five of these tickets
get called up Souter randomly to
basically vote to validate that block
and you have to have at least three you
know three tickets voting and a majority
voting in the affirmative so what that
does is it does two things one analyze
incentives of stake holders and miners
right because effectively the miners
cannot operate outside of the will of
ticket holders who could basically
invalidate blocks if those blocks
violate a rule or a tenant of decreed in
any way what happens if the miners
validate and the stagers don't is the
block invalid the block isn't valid and
the miners lose the reward so the
incentive now for miners is you have to
basically comply so everything from you
know unlike I think Bitcoin Bitcoin is
backward
decoyed isn't so when we have a a change
to the code base basically all the
miners over a period of time which often
times is you know generous you have to
kind of upgrade to be able to now be on
the active or valid copy and so if a
miner for example is working off a
different version of a software like all
those blocks would be invalidated
because you're not on the current and I
guess it works the same way if the
miners don't validate a block then
stickers as well you need both right yes
so you can't eat both right so this
becomes a symbiotic relationship where
both sides need the other but ultimately
ticket holder is effectively or like the
Senate or if you think about a lower
house in the upper house like they hold
more sway and you have to get them
aligned so we have a hybrid proof or
proof eight system but we also have you
know sixty percent of block awards go to
miners 30% goes of ticket holders I mean
then 10% goes into our treasury right
and this is basically where all the
funding for the network comes from so
developers who are building myself
anyone who works with the network where
the Fulton apart time is paid out of
this Treasury that's getting 10% are
available every block reward but that
becomes very very integral to basically
the long-term goals of D credit where we
believe that over time there will be
features that become critically
important right so we released a privacy
implementation on decode a couple months
ago right because privacy is important
the ability to opt into to have private
transactions as a second layer so it's
not on our base chain but as a second
layer we think is important and we think
the constituencies of the indie cred
that would want that as a feature we we
went through a proposal am I going to
build a decks on D credit because we
think that most decks is today are not
really Dex's or two decks is there's
someone in the middle capturing some
rent right and so we think that is not
just important to D cred in terms of
being able to over time be interoperable
with other tokens and have a more you
know active ecosystem but we just think
for the ecosystem we need a real decks
that is permissionless and open to
everyone right so effectively what
decried really is is we're saying look
we think bitcoin solved for some really
large fundamental problems but we think
that we can iterate upon those things
and expand it even and project it out so
I think there will be a future where
you'll have you know corporations that
are built on the blockchain that have
you know a means of exchange have
governance have voting rights I can
program that in any way they want but
there are not subject to necessarily you
know the borders of any single country
right and we already see that being we
begin to have with multinationals where
large multinationals like Apple or a lot
of these large companies they're pretty
powerful and it's kind of hard to put
them within one nation-state like so how
do you regulate and manage an apple or a
Microsoft that is in you know over 100
countries and multiple domiciles and it
effectively many ways behaves like a
nation stating of itself we think that
you know cryptocurrency and blockchain
platforms are that next iteration that
basically take out all all the fiction
in markets and we think that governance
becomes really really critical because
it needs to be transparent needs to be a
fair game that anyone can participate in
and as much as possible you want to
avoid ways for it to be gamed
and so personally I think that delegated
systems create problems right delegated
systems or systems are not quite clear
where there's some intermediary who's
now I'm delegating my vote to a guy just
opens things up for the same problems we
have with nation-states where it's open
for captures open for corruption right
and we think eventually especially as
value accrues to network the stakes get
higher by there's a more effective
there's more incentive to basically game
the system and capture it for by a small
group of people who might be savvy or
whatever might be and and we think those
are huge risks broadly to the crypto
space but specifically 4d cred you know
those are things that we actively are
designed and we actively look at to make
sure and solve for so that's how the
kind of hybrid
mining and staking model works and and
kind of what deke read at the base chain
layer is what are some of the ecosystem
things that either you're most excited
about or you think are the most popular
in and around decried um so I think
fundamentally the thing that I think it
makes you crave very interesting is so
Paula tears are off chain governance
platform what is it called pull a tail
okay and and so it's basically a way for
so I talked about that Treasury it's
basically a way for anyone to propose
ideas that get funded by the Treasury
okay how much is the Treasury in terms
of like on an annual basis right now um
so the I think currently Treasury
depending on the price of D credit is
probably in the range of 12 to 14
million dollars and that's what's
sitting in there that's kind of like
that's will revenue to the treasurer so
that's what's sitting there currently
okay I'm not sure what the annual
revenue is but our burn rate is
basically but we're burning what is
coming in and we're not necessarily like
eroding the current base got it okay
terms of numbers but hopefully you know
as the price goes up then you should be
able to be retaining more and more you
can in dollar terms but any one of the
community anyone anybody can basically
prepare Volterra account propose ideas
and the idea here is that you know that
fund is to be is to fund things that are
beneficial to the network right and I
think the thing that's very interesting
about decried and unique in many ways
it's not just that we have this platform
but it's about how we reach consensus
right and so one of our tag lines is you
know we want to make the best decision
based on the sum total knowledge of the
network and whenever proposals come in
you know one thing I've found to be very
fascinating is that there's a process of
debating the merits of a proposal people
try mean people chime in on social media
and also the platforms and I'm part of
the goal one is to learn so people are
asking questions and pushing things
saying why do we need this why is this
valuable and you find that other people
who are knowledgeable in the community I
essentially trying to inform everyone as
to why this is a good idea so there's a
process of basically in my view
upskilling in terms of knowledge the
community such that ultimately hopefully
we're making the best
I think that process also creates a
system of trust building in many ways
right because you begin to serve
identify folks within the community that
seem to have good ideas who know very
particular things and I think it
attracts people who want to engage in
this very democratic process in many
ways where you have a stake in the game
but you have a say and how basically the
value in the network is spent and doled
out I mean I think in the first year
politie has been live for about 13
months now
a lot of the proposals have come through
either myself heavily around like
marketing so we hired you know ditto as
a PR firm because we needed more
awareness for deke read recently we
passed a proposal that was competitive
for market makers to just improve the
liquidity of dql and certain exchanges
because you know we'd heard and there
are lots of potential investors who are
interested in vesting decried but it's
not liquid enough right so we're able to
basically in many ways just in time
rally around the community kind of like
invest wisely and things that we think
will benefit the community does that
also put it in importance and I'm kind
of thinking out loud here but does that
put an importance on the way that people
communicate the proposals right so it's
almost like the merit of my idea is
important obviously but also the way
that I can rally support around my idea
given that it is more of a democratic
process you know if you and I have the
same quality of idea but I'm better at
rallying support than you are then I
have an advantage so worry about that or
think about it yeah so well I don't know
anything that's a bad thing so typically
the more successful proposals are the
things that increase your likelihood of
being successful is being known right so
for example you've been part of the
community you showed up on our chat
challenge you've asked questions I
typically the best proposals are ones
where Swann has an idea and they start
basically talking to constituents like I
think we should do this here's my idea
and you get feedback right like an
all-time people consensus right and and
you get so you get me a feedback saying
well that sounds great but maybe you
should think about this when you think
about that so what typically happens is
for
vast material proposals by the time they
actually hit the platform like a lot of
fuel in the community I've heard about
it have given feedback and have shaped
the proposal right and not really to me
is what you want you want to be able to
you know go through a process which is
still relatively informal its informal
but it's a way to kind of get buy-in to
what you're doing get people's inputs
potentially you know make compromises
here and there or improve the proposal
such that once it hits Paula Tara you
already have like a group of people who
are like commenting and supporting it
because they've been clued in to what's
being going on right so I think you know
there's a premium on people knowing who
you are you being visible and people
knowing that you're aligned with deke
red and because I the other day it's
still about knowing the energy you're
dealing with
I think we're hyper in particular and
for a good reason
you know we're hyper against
transactional folks we're just coming
they see something that can take and
they can leave or more about people who
see this as a repeated game who are here
for the long haul and and who really
want to stay and help grow the community
got it and I'm assuming that the miners
one of the aspects I'm really interested
in is kind of goes back to a little bit
of the conversation of African countries
and also the hybrid component of Deek
red whether you're mining Bitcoin Deek
read something else this income
generation that crypto unlocks right
it really democratizes the ability for
people to earn a living right and I
think we've seen that in some countries
like the Venezuela where you know the
the income of an average citizen is so
low that literally one single s nine or
s 17 could double or triple their income
right and it's just all you just plug it
in and connect to the internet do you
see that in either African countries
just in crypto in general or do you see
some of this taking hold with D cred in
terms of like income generation or
democratization of the ability to earn
yeah I think so I think it's manifesting
a little bit differently okay with D
cred right so if you think about being
able to sort of minor cryptocurrency
there are this capex related to with
that right so I have to have and even if
it's getting it's a hard way right you
get the hardware and it's becoming even
harder for most chains to actually even
mine it without some serious hardware
now I think in the case of deke red we
have a process through which
contributors get paid for their input
right so even if you're for example
you're organizing meetups on deke red we
have lots of resources you can tap into
presentations things that anyone who's
really bought in and said you can say
look I want to host a meet-up
and you can get paid in reimbursed for
it right that's income right and that
takes just some savvy some ability to
promote and market the event and it's a
you know where I consider like a low
skill level of contribution and you can
get reimbursed for hosting the event
depending on the turnout and that's
pretty transparent and and so that's one
way we have developers who are part of
deke red who are across a number of
African countries and they contribute to
the platform they build code the deploy
code and they get paid indie cred and
you know dick read regardless of where
you are coming into the community as a
developer you get paid the same amount
of money now that becomes very
compelling for them for something from
an African in a secondary city it's very
very low cost of living
I might did some back of a little math
you know I think you know most of our
developers are devs in Africa I probably
making you know three to five X or they
would if they're a full-time deployed
locally at a company right and so all of
a sudden it makes it a very very
compelling case to contribute in
meaningful ways and get paid by the
network in this non-sovereign store
value that you can only you knows that
even exists and you can access anywhere
I think you know and there lots of
protections around that as well such
that you know you're not you know you're
not putting money in a bad bank that's
like you know killing you and taking all
the value and extracting costs if you
have to flee the country because of the
conflict as long as you know your keys
you know you can it sounds like you're
you're really
kind of convinced that that sovereignty
of of crypto you know Bitcoin D credit
cetera the ability to give you the power
as an individual it aligns a lot with
the psychological state that various
people in countries in Africa already
are kind of contributing to their
society or participating in their
society 30 in that mindset you know now
you're getting a piece of technology
that is just kind of putting that in
hyperdrive almost right and if you think
about the Delta right the way I could
explain it is when I think about crypto
in the advanced world of the first world
like it's an evolution right yeah I can
get banking services yeah my banks might
not be the most optimum but I can access
cash I can access a financial system
from non nefarious in the u.s. very very
easily right if I have a good credit
from a good credit risk I can access
lending and loans right and so in many
ways I think crypto is a massive
improvement in many fronts but it's an
evolution I think an African contact
it's a revolution right because you're
dealing now with giving people access to
things that they never had right so I
never had a way to sort of have you know
value stored in a form that now could
become collateral so that I can borrow
against that right I never had a way to
be part of a global network where like I
said I could potentially source right
financial products very very low fiction
very very low cost and I can deploy it
where I am right and I think that makes
a big difference because I think [ __ ] I
think for a lot of people in Africa
crypto behaved with the very first
financial sources product they interact
with in any formal way that's wild
that's absolutely wild for people in the
West to think about right well crypto
based platform of some sort yeah and and
but it does make sense and I think this
is goes to the argument maybe the guys
like multi coin have talked about kind
of the exchanges are quickly becoming
the financial service providers globally
right so if you think of you know kind
of North American ecosystems on the
financial side pretty well-developed
Europe pretty well developed in a number
of countries even China right
well developer cetera the continent of
Africa not well developed right you know
South America a lot of places not very
well developed if you look in kind of
Southeast Asia not very well developed
in a lot of cases and so if that first
interaction is with a crypto exchange or
digital wallet etc those people are
actually at the tip of the spear those
products at building out an entire suite
of financial service products that can
give people access to income to credit
to you know all these tools that you or
I think are kind of normal obviously in
those countries they just either don't
have it in a very popular way or they
don't have access at all and so giving
them access can be pretty um pretty
important yeah I think so and I think
you know when you when you add to the
fact that beyond that I think some of
the tools are building addy cred will
also address some of the people aspects
of crypto around governance around how
decisions are made around empowering
people but also just making sure it's
transparent then you're also solving
other problems that are inherent with
lots of African nation states where you
have poor governance top-down from
governments to institutions and if you
can now create a fairer blockchain based
system where the governance process
cannot be game is fairly clear decision
making could be decentralized right all
of a sudden I think you you have a means
through which you have a new operating
model for institutions and African
continent potentially such that anyone
who is now funding initiatives in Africa
through these channels has certain
assurances that had never had right so
counterparty risk now becomes something
that can be solved because there new
ways I can identify who you are the new
ways I can lock capital and release it
on a certain schedule through smart
contracts all right there are many tools
now you can employ leveraging blockchain
that actually solve for these structural
issues you see in these emerging
economies that all of a sudden if it
takes out all these transactions costs
it makes investing into these nations
more compelling right it makes it more
compelling if the jurisdictions through
which arbitration is handled is on a
blockchain it's not subject to an unfair
giggle system that basically is you know
is in favor of those who are powerful
I'll take any misstep further Alex
Gladstein the the chief strategy officer
at the human rights foundation who's the
first person to turned me on to this
idea he said imagine foreign aid he goes
in a lot of cases foreign aid that goes
into countries all around the world not
just African countries but anywhere in
the world a lot of times that foreign
aids given knowing that there's a
corruption tax right so we're gonna
we're gonna give Nigeria a hundred
million dollars eighty million dollars
maybe will make it to some form of a
charity or an aid type organization
there's another tax at that point right
and the people may get thirty million
dollars of that hundred but that seventy
million dollars that quote-unquote got
taxed bad and one went into the hands of
the people who could other organizations
the government the bank
I mean cetera I mean I think I think the
global or the the legacy global NGO
market is a big ruse like literally it's
a big subsidy for these countries
because if you look at charities just on
average like over half of the monies
that come in just go to operating these
charities right are these NGOs so the
first lump is you're creating jobs for
you know Americans whatever the source
of funding comes from right now that the
piece that goes so that gets into the
country corruption roads a bunch of it
and where does that money typically land
it lands in foreign business accounts
right so also anomalies in Swiss
accounts right powering up in these fees
accounts and it's developing European
economies right because what's the Swiss
bank gonna do it's gonna put into the
system and invest it right so in many
ways am i it's a huge sub seed and
actually and not only does it not
benefit their beneficiaries locally in
these African countries it'll leave this
African countries on the hook for the
debt where most of the benefits are
accrued to the originator of the of the
investment in the first place right and
I think that you know funny enough I
think that even that's one area that I
particularly personally want to see
crypto on blockchain totally just
revolutionized and specially we can give
the aid right to the people right right
you literally avoid all of that nonsense
it's just what's your digital wallet
right and I have a hundred thousand
people now that have digital wallets and
I'm gonna make sure every single person
gets their equal fair share of that
eight right and but even in the
operations of a charity like for example
like some of the work that Bonnie's
charity has been doing any ganda is
remarkable where I think effectively
Biman's covers the operating costs of
the charity
I think the charity gets donations from
other third parties but dollar for
dollar every dollar goes towards
beneficiaries ends up in the hands of
the beneficiary and as a pass of audit
data and see where that money's going
and so I think in many ways I'd love to
see you know blockchain and crypto
basically destroy this market where
frankly the benefices are not receiving
the funding they should yeah so I think
there's a lot of there's a lot of
interesting areas where I think crypto
can bring in transparency reduce
friction and and actually help people
more more so than they're being held in
current systems today what is what's
either the craziest or the the most
inspiring story that you've seen with
somebody on the continent of Africa
interacting with crypto blockchain like
what would be the one story if you could
tell people here's a great example or a
crazy example what would it be hmm
crypto in Africa crazy example
who trying to think I think that you
know like I said early on some of the
examples I've seen is you have you you
have these cottage industries going
around leveraging crypto as a utility
right so for example I'll give an
example there their number of exchanges
across Africa now like real general
exchanges but there's been a whole
industry of effectively where I consider
like liquidity and wholesale providers
that have come into the space okay where
for example I have access to an exchange
in the wherewithal to acquire a Bitcoin
but then I'm reselling that Bitcoin or
access to that to those pools to others
they don't have the wherewithal but I'm
actually giving them utility they pay me
a fee for my trouble right but the the
market is expanding because someone has
seen an opportunity one to get a return
I mean the Bavarian periods of time
across Africa where the price of Bitcoin
was an order of magnitude higher than it
was in other markets like examples
whereas Ababu and subbaiah was close to
the brink of blowing up also it's like
50% higher I think all the time when
when Bitcoin hit 20,000 I got close to
20,000 at one point in some exchanges in
Zimbabwe they come were selling for
$60,000 crazy right and so so when you
think about the margin that's there to
be had of course you were going to enter
that market and try to then inter
mediate it right so there's a lot of
crazy stuff happening where you now have
these sort of like fly-by-night bankers
effectively running these informal shops
but what that is doing is I think it's
increasing your awareness because you
know when you when you weren't a
transaction on my behalf the next
question I'm gonna ask is what did you
do and how did you do it
and I'm effectively trying to eventually
get you out so I think that's helping to
kind of proliferate market I mean like
literally it's hey you and I live in a
village we don't have access to a car we
know someone who has access to a car
they're gonna go to the city they can go
buy X Y or Z thing that's available in
city not available in our village I
picked that up for me and I'll pay you
some fee when you bring it back it's
essentially what's happening up here
right it's just you have access to that
exchange because you've actually gotten
you know how to use it I want Bitcoin
I'd give you some cash
you go buy the Bitcoin I mean there they
would like weirder custody thing
solutions I've seen in Africa where you
know you can buy Bitcoin over the
counter I go to a store I give them some
cash and they give me literally like a
code I thought I said own think it's
really don't give you the secret key or
your private key but they give you a
code that basically is good for a
certain amount of Bitcoin and people
people are trading those receipts right
because it's a store of value somewhere
and it's like it's stamped some out to
value that it's a valid receipt right
but I can basically you know it's always
like go to a pawn shop where I'm like I
give you some cash right you give me a
receipt I represent amount of Bitcoin
look at Bitcoin moon last night I'm
coming back to cash in and getting more
cash so you have all these sort of
interesting ways that people are now
creating a user experience that allows
for others to use it right and taking
advantage of these opportunities and
this happens in another example that I
use a lot is innovation a comes out of
necessity a lot of times right and so if
you're there you don't have access to
the exchange to actually buy it but you
want the benefits of the store value
people come up with these types of
things my favorite example of all of
this is the economies that are built
within prisons in the United States
right so they trade toilet paper they
trade ramen noodles they trade
cigarettes right all these things that
begin to have monetary type properties
because they become medium of exchanges
let's rush stores of value it's because
innovation is the product of necessity
they don't have anything yeah and so I
think that that is you know it's funny
how this replicates over and over and
over again in countries all around the
world and now we're seeing I think
Bitcoin and crypto be the beneficiary of
it across the ecosystem before I wrap up
rapid-fire questions what um what would
you say is the most important company in
crypto today other than Deek read about
a jump oh and Sadie crash
the most important company other than
decrypt so this is one of popped up to
mind placeholder okay Oh interesting
and I think the reason for that so I
think I think personally for me and Mike
my crypto journey crispiness key has
been very very pivotal so this I don't
know placeholder is an investment firm
based in New York run by two guys Chris
Byrne and ski and joel's all right
Joe and I grow yeah yeah that's right
and and they've been big proponents of D
credit along with a whole bunch of other
stuff but but have been pretty early and
done a lot of work in terms of
publishing their ideas and things like
that yeah and so I think it's released
personally in that I think a lot of my
early crypto journey I kind of relied on
Chris quite a bit he was quite
accessible right just bugging him asking
with stupid questions and so that's one
but I also think that I kind of brought
him up Chris and place a little in
particular for just so like the culture
of asking questions and trying to figure
out what's next all right so this idea
that you know innovation didn't end with
Bitcoin but there's so much more we can
uncover right and the whole ethos around
them really trying to invest in the
future trying to not just in terms of
making investments and companies but
also kind of pushing further like
research position paper is I mean I
think a lot of my perspective on how I
see the markets have come from some
other like seminal Blancos posts on you
know fad protocols and idea that you
know okay maybe values not gonna accrue
the middleware and the fact that they're
they're more than willing in many ways
to contradict themselves as they get
more information alright so the protocol
thesis was we think that our value is
going to accrue to these base layer
chains and as more information as the
market is evolved you can see how their
positioning is changing and they're now
saying look things are changing things
are evolving we think the dynamic is
shifting and that certain things and our
thesis is maturing and evolving and I
think just having that culture and ethos
that you don't know what the future
looks like but we want to be part of it
and want to be part of bringing it to
bear I think not only serves the
ecosystem well but in many ways I think
it's
it's a lot of the basis on which D cred
is also built this idea that we want to
integrate it away into the future we
want to see what's next and we want to
be able to build implement and execute
on the features that the network is
going to need for sure what's the one
regulation you would change or improve
if you could in what domicile here in
the US wherever you want you pick the
one regulation hmm I like talking to
people who've global mindset now you
first you gotta make multiple decisions
so so there's a body so well I don't
know if I'll call it a regulation okay
so I think you know their number of laws
but the whole body of laws that have
basically allowed monetary policy global
monetary policy power to reside in the
United States right I think if you think
about you know and so holds a whole
number of laws but right now the big
shots no but I mean there I mean after
the Patriot Act they're a whole bunch of
laws around global financial systems
that got passed through most people even
know what was going on right but over
the years increasingly the US has gotten
a much more dominant position and say I
mean all commodities are priced in
dollars so basically the whole of Africa
relies on Fed monetary policy that
effectively determines the price of
goods coming out of African countries
that's a problem right that's a
sovereignty problem for Africa that's a
that's a right and so my so I think that
whole body of laws that essentially you
know backs the US as a reserve currency
but it also has weaponized a dollar as a
as a tool to cajole and and and kind of
beat countries into doing the bidding of
the US I think I think I think those set
of laws are not only bad for the world I
think they're ultimately bad for the
United States because I think invariably
what it's created is it's fractured all
the post-world War two institutions
where every country felt that they had a
say or a seat at the table and it's
forcing other powerful dumbest houses
say that any way in which we can weaken
the
of currency we're going to do right and
so it set the game that Biscay has now
said look one way or the other were
coming after the dollar that's the
Chinese whether it's the Russians
alright I think ultimately that's bad
for the United States it's almost like
it's good short term long bad term and
what you do if you look at like the
political climate in the u.s. so there's
a group of people who they call
themselves never Trump er Trump errs
right which basically anything other
than Donald Trump
we're that's what they're in for right
well that's kind of what's happening in
the geopolitical world where you're
getting China Russia you know bunch of
these economies and governments are
saying you know basically never us right
they're just saying like anything else
other than a US based or US dollar based
system is better what are our other
options right and so I think that
actually in some weird way the US
government is driving more awareness and
potential adoption of Bitcoin than they
realize by weaponizing their currency by
doing all of this stuff because almost
like they've they realized they were
powerful they started to implement that
power then they abuse that right and
then eventually what ends up happening
everyone revolts exactly right and and
you know it's one thing if you're a
government and your citizens are
thinking about a revolution because
you've got a lot of control right we see
that in you know Hong Kong and China
right now etc and there's just
challenges for a group of volunteers or
people to kind of coordinating cetera
but when it's other countries that are
revolting against you and they're
banding together I don't care how
powerful you are right you can't fight
everybody all the time and so I think
that that's a a really good point you're
right and I think what makes it worse is
you know the US has a government is
gonna fight a war on multiple fronts
because there's a revolution from within
there's a backlash from within and
there's populist movements around this
idea that globalization hasn't been fair
to everyone right and so I think the
u.s. is facing an internal mutiny on
some level and is now facing a crumbling
of its allegiances internationally all
in the mean to own the while I think we
haven't figured you know cooked
regulations it's still kind of a very
great area and meanwhile other countries
are accelerating full steam ahead you
know I think we need to wake up as a
country to really try to figure out what
we want to be when we grow up or grow
older right and it's not it's not
looking good because we're just so in
this sort of gray area and um you know
things need to change
yeah what's the most important book
you've ever read oh the most important
book and too fragile okay why a Nassim
Taleb well I think because it's so I
mean I had my first degrees in economics
and it's probably one of the first books
I read that had a very much more
practical view on so like behavioral
economics right so beyond the theory and
things you learn it really talks about
fundamentally you know certain things
that make you resilient as an individual
as a company as an entity and this idea
of antifragility right where that where
you know you're able to you know things
that don't kill you actually make you
stronger right I think just the the tone
of the book and and how it kind of puts
everything on top of its head
it sort of creates I need for me the way
I kind of read it into pretty it is it
for so you want to think differently but
it also tells you that there's a
different way like it's another way
there's no way to look at things and
another it's a better way to do things
right and I think that's part of also
the attraction to crypto and and and and
D credit and blockchain is this idea
that the system we have today many ways
works but there's always a better way
and there's no reason why you know
things because they've been the same way
for 50 a hundred years needs to remain
the same they need to evolve before I
finish up I'll let you ask me a question
to bring us home but aliens real or not
you believe No whoa hold on you're one
of only three people I've ever cut your
is blasphemy on this show what why uh
why are you a non-believer you don't
believe in aliens no I don't believe in
aliens be quiet
why because I think the whole design
of the system of the earth of the
universe or anything I think I was a
created by God and God created man and
ultimately everything was designed for
whatever his goals are in terms of okay
so humans in the population and I don't
think God hedged so I don't think God
created another race somewhere else just
in crazy school what about animals huh
no but they're all on earth right so
everything right so why do you create
all the other planets I don't know
that's a good question but we haven't
found Williams yet so I am I'm living
within the understanding and the
framework for which I think you know I
interact with daily and I can kind of
say his real but somebody I'm a 34
aluminum I'm sure you are
I saw a video recently online that I
tweeted which was a I think it's a
octopus or a jellyfish or some kind of
hybrid of it deep in the ocean and it
was flying you're like you know gliding
in the water and it was going over top
of various what I'll call kind of
environments so one was more of a rocky
kind of light-coloured one one was a
darker looks like kind of like seaweed
type environment etc and as it was going
over each one of the environments it was
changing colors and it was completely
camel
it did it and at the end of the video it
goes down into the rocks and it
literally looks like it hardens and
turns into a rock Wow and all I kept
thinking to myself is humans may be the
least prepared species on this planet to
deal with bad [ __ ] because something
like that is incredibly I also think
that if you also kind of follow the you
know not crazy
what's the austere core of creationism
if you follow this idea that you know
things evolved Oh an ocean yeah and
evolutionary theory like a lot of things
have to happen in perfect balance for
life to actually happen on earth agreed
and I think that I just don't think that
there's anywhere else in the solar
system where all
things align so perfectly to create life
alright last question for you are
dinosaurs real well we have skeletons of
dinosaurs who dug up so did we dig them
up I think if you went over three with
me on aliens things of the ocean and
dinosaurs
everything is here everything has
evolved evolves from here I just share
point against the facts oh look look it
uh there are not a lot of people who
come in here and say they don't believe
aliens but that may be a good bet is the
fact that everyone else has consensus
that aliens exist maybe the the the
counterintuitive bet is actually the
right one yeah it's how you make out
size gains being you know the other side
of the trade with the crowd exactly what
one question you have for me to finish
up um question for you ah I guess what
makes you really optimistic about the
the crypto space like why have you
dedicated your life and all of your time
and effort into the space like what
really gets you up it's the ultimate
speaking truth to power hmm like there's
a lot of people who do a lot of things
and they rely on their ability to
coordinate resources they rely on their
ability to use information arbitrage
they rely on their ability to use
violence to do things to other parts of
the population in every country that
puts people at a systemic disadvantage
right and so whether you look at
something like inflation that actually
drives wealth inequality whether you
look at something like seizing of assets
things like that I think that Bitcoin
crypto and and even blockchain more
generally has the ability to empower
people to fight back and the part that I
like about it especially having your
deployed in war environment etc is that
it's a peaceful way to fight back right
right you you don't have to kind of
revolt in the sense that people have
historically thought of in terms of you
know
go fight or protest you can do it in a
way of just I choose to opt out I choose
Plan B right I choose to store my wealth
somewhere else or I choose to earn my
income by securing a network etc and I
think that that's a pretty powerful idea
that just hasn't been around you know
for very long and I think it ultimately
become more more popular as people kind
of get aware of it awesome cool I mean
listen I appreciate you you taking the
time to do this you are now the resident
expert on off the chain of all things
crypto and the African continent so
we'll have to bring you back as things
continue to evolve and do this again in
the future for sure thanks a lot